avec la copie 19 le télétravail est
passé de l'exception à la norme ou
presque deux trois quatre jours parfois
toute la semaine et salariés peuvent
désormais travailler de chez eux
un an après comment juge-t-il cette
évolution et les patrons sont-ils prêts
à poursuivre l'expérience questions
réponses dans ce reportage à tour de
florent clavel voilà maintenant six mois
que carine teyssandier et en télétravail
la visioconférence un réflexe pour cette
chargée de communication dans une
entreprise tourangelle après une période
de chômage partiel elle a commencé à
travailler chez elles pendant le 2ème
confinement avec le recul
une expérience qu'elle juge positive
dans l'ensemble mais qui ne remplace pas
la présence en entreprise
l'effet positif du travail on est
opérationnel plus plus rapidement et le
présentiel à amen amen ça de bon c'est
les dossiers avancent véritablement on
est en contact avec les collègues avec
lesquels on a besoin d'interaction pour
travailler dans l'entreprise de karine
le télétravail est devenue la norme
trois jours chez soi deux jours en
entreprise voilà le régime pour la
plupart des 70 salariés d'abord
contrainte par la crise sanitaire
son utilisation va perdurer a sur son
dirigeant les salariés mais aussi
l'entreprise et ont trouvé leur
équilibre
on s'est rendu compte que il y avait
absolument aucune perte de productivité
des collaborateurs en télétravail
donc c'était quelque chose qui
effectivement fonctionner par contre
c'est le dosage qui est important pour
cette spécialiste le télétravail doit
maintenant trouver un cadre on estime
qu'au delà de trois jours par semaine en
télétravail il est difficile d'être
performant et d'avoir un bien-être en
télétravail parce qu'on a besoin à un
moment donné de revoir ses collègues de
faire le point avec son manager
aujourd'hui on est face à une évolution
d'organisation avec un management
présentiel distant ciel et des
organisations hybride et y font tenir
compte pour car la joie où il est
impératif que les entreprises cern
précisément les envies de chaque salarié
pour que le télétravail perdure
viendront ensuite les accords
d'entreprise pour en fixer les règles